[Applaudissements]
les durs non j'aime et du retard ils
s'inquiéter bah oui m'inquiéter je fais
pas viable c'est bien mais vous
connaissez la personne bien sûr il
paraît que vous avez été des courses
laurence ghanéen c'est ça n'importe quoi
si ce qu'on va dire qu'on va lire avec
vous avez fait là qu'est ce que je te
dis n'importe quoi non fait j'ai fait la
première partie du concert de florent
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'ai lu que vous avez fait c'est quoi
votre album donc c'est double enceinte
comme ça et voilà c'est un meilleur va
s'est pas arrêté là j'ai pas mal est
fait la première moitié du couple on
s'est fait la première partie de florent
pagny mais souvent des blousons qu'on ne
vienne pas un oui c'est vrai j'ai pas
peur que le tribunal et moi je termine
et j'ai rien rater de la tv